مصائب تيك توك عند ميتا وسناب شات فوائده
فالتطبيق الصيني التابع لشركه باي دانس
حسم امر حظره في امريكا وكذلك كندا
وبدا من العشرين من مارس لتيك توك في
اجهزه ثمانيه الاف موظف في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومن هنا شب نزاع اخر في الفضاء
الالكتروني بين اكبر اقتصادين في العالم
شبكه سي ان بي سي اشارت الى ان هذا الحظر
قد يسمح لشركتين ميتا وسناب شات ان تسحب
بساط سوق الاعلانات من تيك توك لتنتعش بعد
عام مضطرب اي انه نعمه لهما مقاطع فيروسيه
هكذا تصفها واشنطن خاصه انها تفشت بين
مليار مستخدم وفق بيانات مركز بيول
للابحاث
67% من المستخدمين هم من مراهقين الولايات
المتحده و16 من اليافعين يدمنون على
استخدام التيك توك
ومع قرار تعطيله سيتجه تدفق استخدام
الشباب الى المنصات الاخرى لتشغيل
فيديوهات فيسبوك وسناب شات سبوت لايت
وانستجرام ريلز ويوتيوب شورتس فبعد ان سجل
التيك توك تحكما في
32% من الاعلانات الرقميه في جميع انحاء
العالم سيفسح المجال بحظره لتفوق شركات
اخرى
تعددت اسباب واشنطن في وقف استخدامه يقود
الامن القومي ويسرق البيانات الحساسه
ويؤثر على النمو العاطفي للاطفال معترفه
ولو ضمنيا بان ساحه الصراع باتت رقميه اذ
اسمت مشروع القانون رد على الخصوم
التكنولوجيين لامريكا